La I want to say thank you very much my
special recording at the dynasty
typewriter on Wednesday December 14th is
sold out I can't thank you all enough
for it we're gonna have a fun [ __ ]
time uh also here that they don't serve
alcohol so hey maybe you want a pregame
y'all I'll see you on the 14th
Grand Rapids Michigan I'll be there
December 9th and 10th get your tickets
for those shows on my website at
ryansickler.com
[Music]
I want to make a very special
announcement here I'm excited to say
that
um I have the crab Feast podcast back
under my control okay so uh it's every
artist's goal to get their you know
property back to them we got it all
right so
um
if you don't know about the crab Feast
um but a lot of you do I want to say
this I'm on the road meet and greets
people come up and rocking with you
since the feast man the feast the feast
the crab Feast is a podcast that I did
with Jay Larson it's a storytelling
podcast Audio Only
um we did it for about seven and a half
years there's 350 some episodes hell if
you if you listen to two a week it would
take you three and a half years to get
through it but it's a phenomenal library
that I'm very proud of
um it's what
um preceded the Honeydew for me and it's
got all the same favorite guests you
love sagora Bert Kreischer Bill Burr
Christina p uh you name it there's and
they're all different stories too so if
you love the Honeydew you gotta check
out the crab Feast
um subscribe to it today it's still
getting a ton of downloads already
there's an active community on Facebook
that goes through every episode uh and
it's been almost gone for four years now
so
um feasters let them know uh honeydew
fans if you are looking for you're all
caught up on a honeydew and you're like
what else can I listen until I'm telling
you go listen to The Crab Feast it is a
fantastic fun uh storytelling podcast
you know there you'll get like man I got
this weird ghost story in a near death
and a marriage story into this where
that's what you know I the Honeydew for
me was the crab fees needed to have a
baby and I just focus on highlighting
the low lights here so go check it out
it's available everywhere you get
Podcast it's audio only like I said
subscribe
um join the fan pages have fun with it
I'm gonna be promoting it every week
here on the Honeydew now that it's uh
back in in control here so I'm very
excited about that thank you feasters
thank you honeydew fans enjoy the feast
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media uh if you're watching on
YouTube I want to say Please Subscribe
thank you all as I say every week this
community continues to grow which
[ __ ] blows me away it really does so
thank you for that hit that subscribe if
you gotta have more then you gotta check
out the patreon I keep saying it we just
talked to a lady who had two buttholes
uh try to introduce her to the lady with
two [ __ ] uh talk to a dude that died
dude was dead for three and a half
minutes uh and and was brought back I'm
telling you it's five bucks a month we
haven't raised the price one bit you got
well over 100 episodes of it if you sign
up for a year you get over a month free
and you're getting the Honeydew a day
early you're getting it ad free and
you're getting at no additional cost all
right so if you or someone you know has
that story that has to be heard please
submit it to honeydew podcast
gmail.com all right Grand Rapids I will
be there this week I think December 9th
and 10th and then La I'm shooting my
special Wednesday December 14th at the
dynasty typewriter uh the first show is
sold out and there's a low ticket
warning for the second show now so use
code sickler at checkout you'll get half
off your tickets all right that's the
biz you guys know what we do over here
we're highlighting these low lights and
listening to the stories behind the
storytellers very excited to have this
Storyteller back on the do ladies and
Gentlemen please welcome Ari shafir
thanks bro you know I just I was like I
was looking at the honey DeMille and I
was thinking it was a cantaloupe and I
was like why do they have so many
cantaloupe pictures
this one here this is one of my favorite
shots this guy's passing up honeydew to
go get cancer get the camera what a
loser unless he's like giving I could
see Steve Simone doing that where it's
like no everybody's gonna want the
Honeydew yeah let me just get
cantaloupe's good enough for me I'll
suffer
um welcome back thanks bud
um and congrats on the special thank you
how many millions views at this point
all of them I think
um yeah yeah it's almost up to four what
was your goal did you make a goal for
yourself I wanted in a month I wanted a
million and a month and I did that and
how many days three two days yeah it was
impressive too yeah promote it tell
everybody it's a it's my it's my [ __ ]
Opus man it's I worked for five years on
this one did you yeah real mindfully
like preparing material but uh just like
jokes that work in clubs all about like
one topic and try to make it hold
together and and keep people's attention
I did it in places where there's no Jews
where there's tons of Jews where that
made sure it worked for everybody
so [ __ ] mindful about it but uh yeah
I'm stoked on it it looks good it's on
YouTube right now yeah yeah yeah people
are I was talking to Schultz about it he
was like I told you like helping me with
like thumbnails and [ __ ] like that he
goes yeah people people like I'm like
and I'm like I was like oh I know people
will like it I just want him to see it
yeah you know that's what I was just
saying like with before we were
recording like do you remember when we
just wanted to tell jokes just right
yeah get up and tell jokes you talk to
your friends the unurban it was like it
was like hey I got this [ __ ] joke to
work about check her like oh that's
hilarious and now you're like hey I'm
figuring out the algorithm I don't even
know what that word was yeah the [ __ ]
are you talking about what is this part
of [ __ ] data majority of the force
you've had to talk about social media
editors hit me up for real I'm looking
for somebody right now legit social
media editor who really can take that
[ __ ] over the top fans do good jobs too
I know somebody just sent me this hit me
up I'll show you this
gmail.com
and so me and Tim were talking about how
in in um Harry Potter the [ __ ]
Bankers are clearly Jews somebody did a
[ __ ] match stuff
it's just my special
yeah that's the best once you put it out
there I love Stephen comes back dude I
passed out on the roads are so tired
they're so talented the entirety of the
internet is unequalable yeah you know to
it's like I don't care how good you
could be Jon Jones if you throw the
whole everybody at him he will lose yeah
you know yeah and the the level of humor
on all of Internet absolutely there's
some just like 19 year old kid out there
kicking [ __ ] out and you're like as
funny as [ __ ] nailed it yeah I did a
joke about uh Down Syndrome kid playing
football in Philadelphia
and I was just like hey you know I saw
this video and somebody just goes was it
shangelis
dude
it doubled me over
but then I was like that's from the
[ __ ] great that was [ __ ] great it
wasn't even [ __ ] on me I was like
[ __ ] well I met I went back to like
20 minutes later I was like hey man I'm
not usually a fan of you guys piping up
but that was [ __ ] great
[Music]
um all right so yeah
youtube.com
just type in Ari shafir Jew and it'll
come up and then are you going on a tour
after this as well are you going out
live right now I'm gonna be in uh I'm
gonna be in um
Pittsburgh and Salt Lake and and Tampa
and and uh I don't know about San Jose
and then I'm gonna hit Europe up yeah
hit Europe up yeah I don't know I was
talking about sagora how cool it is you
get to [ __ ] play Europe yeah I mean
to be able to sell to is it blow your
mind it blows my mind that I sell
tickets anywhere first of all but Canada
blew me away yeah I was like damn
Edmonton Edmonton was wild too we had to
because
really yeah
really that's your genetics you've done
shitty things
and I'm like shut up and they screaming
their way
yeah we're all belligerent this lady in
Edmonton was too she was belching and
[ __ ] and then you can't even tell her
quietly man we have to ask you to leave
it'd be like what they know she wasn't
like that's what I'm saying this was
she's like I'm 40 hard I was like you're
not deaf you're hard of hearing uh
there's a difference you're trying to
glom on somebody else is killing the
whole time I didn't bring my hearing
aids her boyfriend got up and left the
table oh wow dude why would you not
bring your hearing aids to an audio
event she also waited until the pandemic
to find out that she was deaf I said
you've been screaming like this your
whole life at people and you just
thought that was normal she's like yeah
and then when the pandemic I couldn't
see her it was in the dark she's right
on the this is the problem I couldn't
tell because some people don't know how
to [ __ ] order quietly so I couldn't
tell if this was an order or if this was
a server asking for more drinks I'm I'm
letting it go until I finally hear the
boyfriend and he I didn't realize he
left they were right on that edge where
the light hits you know what I mean you
could see their shoes that kind of [ __ ]
and I'm just like who the [ __ ] is that
error there in the darkness and they
threw her ass out good that yes that's
what I'm saying it's funny too because
it's that moment of like oh you have to
be kind to the deaf but then you're like
nah I'm gonna I'm gonna see everybody
equal here and your disability does not
give you the [ __ ] right to be disrupt
the show [ __ ] you're an [ __ ] you
need wheelchair access Fair yes you need
me to let you Heckle not fair no yeah
you can sit quietly in your [ __ ] role
right on out that ramp okay throw
somebody out at the store but I was
doing Jew I did it there once you did
they threw somebody out and he had to
attach his leg no I was like
and it was like dude [ __ ] you I'm a big
fan I was like oh you gotta go man it's
just too much and then he stood up and
he starts tying it on and it was that
moment of like [ __ ] but then he's like
lean in I'm like [ __ ] you're
gonna take forever to throw out too
you're not even gonna go quietly
attach it outside
I know that God the worst possible guy
if I would have took my crutches
what are you gonna do to him
oh my God this is terrible dude yeah I
forgot about it somebody reminded me and
I was like oh yeah
that is crazy
he just kept mouthing off
oh God damn dude
it took so long to it I'm like of course
the guy who's gonna take the absolute
longest to get out of this [ __ ] room
is the one I had to throw out I couldn't
have gotten Usain Bolt out of here
it would have been out before those
blades either was it wasn't one of those
Olympics it was an old like tied on like
yeah
[Laughter]
oh that's terrible I'm a big fan and you
got like one second you're like I either
gotta go sorry or you gotta go lean in
oh that's what happened with me is that
really wait she's like they're throwing
me out because I don't have my hearing
aid I go is that really what's going on
the table goes no right away yeah we
were like get her to [ __ ] up that [ __ ]
you're never hearing it get rid of her
what world do you think we live in
I love when you're a bad excuse where
you're like I know that's not right I
don't know what is right but I know your
excuse is wrong oh [ __ ] dude foreign
let's talk about you said you wanted to
talk about some uh old jobs I was trying
to remember because I was like what do I
like talking about yeah some
embarrassing or [ __ ] firing like what
what was your first job my first firing
was Domino's what was your first job
Arlington National Cemetery really yeah
you know it what did you do I laid pipe
bro
how old were you 16. it's the first time
you're allowed to work okay you know and
you can work it and what made you get a
job there did you know someone someone
suggested any Jew gets any job I've had
an end someone I think my uncle knew
someone who whatever and summertime they
need more weed Pickers and and pipe
layers really yeah you'd get these
[ __ ] giant long way longer in this
room pick them up of a truck Hot you
need gloves PVC the [ __ ] yeah and
they lay them male to female and just
stick them in they had this little lash
and were like you throw a drainage what
are they it was just to water the law
irrigation yeah and so you do that lay
them in turn it on then you go to the
next one pick those up you know
unbuckler and this is among all the the
Tombstones wow really yeah but you were
never there after dark so it wasn't
creepy no but still it's it's that's
intense I feel like it's an intense
place to work like I feel like you
couldn't [ __ ] up anything there
and yet
I mean dude when it was like flood of
the [ __ ] Soldier out of a god oh yeah
no I didn't do that but okay so I was
good dude these guys I had never met
black people before what yeah they were
16. yeah I mean I knew a teacher here or
there no student I grew up Orthodox
Jewish all in all you went to Hebrew
school the whole time yeah we had one
black family
you got one black Jew on your shirt
right there Sammy Davis bro right there
yeah Jesus was probably probably for
sure yeah for sure Brown
um I mean he probably lost some [ __ ]
Tan in that cave but he was only in
there
he got a nice time yeah right he got
bronze up there he's like damn give me
some [ __ ] banana boat up here he
asked for water but give him that banana
boat
yeah I never really met black people
before and they were there and drove
there was a couple summer hires but
mostly just people were just clothes
yeah so what are we talking like
hundreds of people to take care of this
property no it was maybe 15 people okay
the whole Cemetery yeah in the
Horticulture Department there was one
old guy we'd play spades every day at
lunch yeah and I knew the game a little
bit but the way they would play was such
Panache it wasn't like uh you know
you're holding on to [ __ ] seven of
Spades and like you know when you get
like you play one heart and then it's
time you're like you know I can Trump
hard now so the king gets played and you
just wait and instead of going like no I
got that that's how I play they were
like yeah no and they pull it in and it
was like yeah
damn listen that's that oh my god look
when I went to uh I went to Catonsville
community college okay my uh two years
to get my AAA and my freshman year there
my first year the Third 13th grade there
what's your Alcoholics Anonymous my AAA
is uh uh associate's degree oh yeah
General Studies bro too late gives out
the other areas so
these guys are always playing the black
guys are always playing Uno in the
cafeteria and they're playing
aggressively like that and one day
one of the guys said you didn't call Uno
and the guy's like [ __ ] you I did too
and he's like no you didn't he was like
[ __ ] yeah I did and the dude picked up a
chair cracked him across the head it
fractured his skull they had to land the
helicopter on the [ __ ] property and
rushed this dude to the hospital
over Uno and immediately it signs
everywhere no more card playing no more
dice no more gambling like done
bro but for all ages that's what they
exactly not all ages fun for four to
fourteen crack them over the [ __ ] wow
yeah it's crazy otherwise he wouldn't
somebody else would be like no no I
heard him so what how did you get so all
right so 16 you're into this thing and I
mean do you want to do I'm a G1 well
yeah it was cool to have a summer job
yeah remember I love summer jobs
Landscaping working poles yes and it was
like you still did you didn't have the
laziness yet but man they taught me how
to be lazy
they taught me way it was just like you
did the job they tell you yeah yeah so
we had one time we had to pick out weeds
by the near the parking lot and and I'm
you know I'm [ __ ] picking out weeds
and putting with this big trash can and
one of the guys it was just me and him
on duty and he's like nah nah nah nah
and I was like what do you mean he goes
nah dude and we got some newspaper and
he just wadded it up put him like
halfway up the [ __ ] giant trash can
and he goes all we gotta do is cover
those newspapers yeah and I was like
what dude black people are so smart and
just we covered that up with a layer of
weeds and then we just slept in between
like tourist cars yeah
in the shade of the [ __ ]
parking lot in between some cars of
tourists oh God damn dude yeah it was
great and then he goes he'll pick us up
at 4.
he was probably 25 30. he was a he was a
full-time job yeah yeah
um
yeah God I forgot about that guy dude so
the black guys I used to work with at
UPS were so [ __ ] funny and so fun
shout out to UPS Baltimore Hub primary
one Joe Avenue and they would do this
thing in the loading thing where and I I
worked with him so I knew but then I
became a supervisor so I knew and I'm
like yeah you can't be doing that [ __ ]
anymore
quarter of the way up they would build a
false wall instead of all the way the
back they build it here and then they
would just take packages and Chuck them
over the wall and then stack the wall up
to close it and then just build out the
rest so you it looks like they're doing
it it looks like half that truck's full
and it's not wow and they're just
throwing it because everyone's supposed
to be like Tetris nice city they're just
yeah nah I love it it's so smart what a
what a game the system
I learned about black humor
I had never seen black Hume before which
this was the wildest one you'll make a
joke whatever the joke was in the moment
and then they'll just repeat it and get
an equal laugh
I was like what if you're like why the
chicken start to get this like
and everyone would just laugh equally
and I was like
like what how many times can you tag it
with the same exact
ly it was I was like Wow black humor is
interesting
um uh so we did that so the one time I
got in trouble so I was good and he gave
me wand Duty which was you just instead
of lifting these heavy pipes
you get to just like go to some of the
the flower beds and just you attach us
they call the magic wand on top of a
hose and it would kind of go up with
like a hose attachment so you know
you're just like watering the water the
the flower beds it's real light instead
of like the [ __ ] massive
um piping thing
and
I got Tomb of the Unknown Soldier and I
was watering it it was great it was just
like easy work you know you didn't have
to [ __ ] lug [ __ ] but is there is in
the soldier standing right there too
well you're going are you buying them no
sorry there is too many on a soldier
Okay Okay Okay and those the Marines
were there and they that was the the
coolest [ __ ] gig they can get because
all they got to do is March up and down
all those guys would just do push-ups
all day they would trade shifts so like
I gotta work every six hours for two
hours it goes I'll just do four hours
straight they're Marines they can handle
this and then I have two days off and
they would just sit there playing cards
and doing push-ups all day oh they're
not just standing still the whole time
like the British guard when they're on
duty they do oh okay then they're in the
[ __ ] Hut they're just having a good
time I See This was um Eternal Flame
excuse me on a flame okay yeah JFK
and this [ __ ] stream of water because
it goes up and then down this stream
just shoots up and then right into the
[ __ ] hit a flame there is no way dude
yeah what happened it's out now yeah you
did not I did [ __ ] it's out and
there's all these Asian tours you put
the eternal flame out yeah I'm sorry
Jake
yeah there's all these Asian tourists
around and it's just this water shoots
out goes right into the [ __ ] hole I
mean I'm on the outside there's this
ring of flowers I'm on the outside of
them just just I mean there's all these
like tourists these Chinese tourists
whatever and they're just like the
Flames out you could tell they're like
looking up in their book like what does
Eternal mean
um because it's out what are you doing
are you [ __ ] yourself [ __ ]
myself and who do you [ __ ] tell I
mean I I thought I mean I'm 16 so I'm
like I gotta relocate it's treason it's
not just like I [ __ ] up at work I'm
going to jail Maybe
it's JFK he's beloved also
listeners
I feel like the Eternal Flame should go
out as easily as a little hose is
[ __ ] firing off the top what happened
to the Rain somebody yeah for real for
real
well
they did have I guess a [ __ ] gas like
a pilot light it did pop back on after
about 30 seconds it really did yeah it
felt like forever and then it just comes
back on and I was like [ __ ] uh that's
not the first time it's happened then
did you ask anybody or no I didn't tell
anybody a word I didn't tell anybody I
was so nervous you look at those tours
you're like
shut up dude I'm Matt Edgar did this
once these [ __ ] cars in the store and
and he's not a good driver yeah and I
saw him back up I believe a Benz slammed
into a Porsche
um and then he goes [ __ ] and he looks
and I'm by the back door you know where
it goes to smoke and I'm the only one
out there and I had done that job before
and he's like this and I go
he's like then he just Parts it to tell
a word and I'm like dude you didn't do
it on purpose these are rich
[ __ ] and you didn't break you
yeah
um
yeah that was fun damn dude put out the
Eternal [ __ ] flame [ __ ]
I feel bad now that is treason that is
treason I mean not in a way and
accidentally it's not I mean
Jesus Christ we'd lay these pipes and
then as soon as it was on it was so hot
it's DC summer yeah you know muggy and
muggy yeah [ __ ] it we would just dance
through the [ __ ] through the
sprinklers we just dance through them it
was so nice we got yelled at a bunch we
got yelled at a bunch we didn't show the
respect man I um when I used to deliver
so I would deliver uh the New York Times
all over I'd start in Baltimore City and
my route would take me down to Annapolis
to the Naval Academy and I didn't
realize I figured it out but there would
be a guy on post and every time a car
would drive by he'd have to walk it was
a gate in front of the Naval Academy
he'd have to walk from this side to that
side okay and I didn't catch it the
first couple times and I'm there every
[ __ ] night Monday to Friday and I see
it and then man I just start circling
back and just making this [ __ ]
keep I was like oh he's gotta go and
every I would just go up turn around
come back go up there I'm dying laughing
he's [ __ ] up
that's nice
I love talking to people like that it's
so fun so they don't know it yeah yeah I
used to this Jamie on on Rogan's podcast
where I like you know I was talking that
it's like slump and I see him like get
up and like lower the camera I didn't
notice it you know something nags at you
but you don't know and then I'm like
talking again and then I get to see him
like raise a camera and I was like oh
and I'm just like yeah
and I'm just hurting myself I'm just off
camera on the biggest podcast in the
world but he's like
just remembering all this [ __ ] now
one guy was like
um uh we saw a Mercedes he goes what you
call that and I'm like Mercedes-Benz he
goes that's called black man's dream
that's how he told you yeah and I was
like that's cool this same guy one day
he goes uh hey look at my belt buckle
and and he just he had had his dick just
right just the head above that I mean
it's like Liz belt buckle and I was
staring around because it made no sense
dicks can't get that above the [ __ ]
waistline I was like what I'm just
staring at it
what is that thing above your belt
buckle holy dudes dude I swear they
don't give a [ __ ] yeah and a color of a
head of a dick I've never seen before
look at my [ __ ] look at my [ __ ] look
at this nip is that a spider bite yeah
never never because they suck
I'll tell every one of your seven female
listeners you guys [ __ ] suck
have some fun do a little titty slap
yeah that was wild
um is that the first time you saw a
black penis
I didn't suck until till months later
we had uh God damn that was a fun job we
would lie because it was so hot we'll
wait we finished all the you know
unloading the truck and we're just
waiting to get picked up by a big
suburban and it was just hot and we if
we saw an open grave we would just get
in it it was shady it's cool yeah you
get in it yeah we get yelled at a lot I
was gonna say wouldn't that be one for a
soldier coming yo yeah yeah 100 but the
soldier wasn't there yet but you don't
have to water that or you didn't party
yeah they had a trick truck coming like
scoop it out and get it all even you
know for whatever but you didn't have to
do any of that like maintenance for
those we argued it where though it's
like it's disrespectful like to whom
there's no one in here yeah they're
dancing over the graves for sure
disrespectful yeah lying in an unused
grave
that's just a hole in the ground
it was beautiful you ever been there yes
it's gorgeous yeah
and they have some celebrities there too
Joe Lewis is buried there and uh Abner
Doubleday I think and um
baseball yeah yeah you had to get buried
there I think you're gonna do 20 years
to get a full plot 20 years or purple
heart or killed in service which I guess
because Purple Heart for being killed
right it's not just injured you get a
purple heart for no you'd be alive
but if you get killed that also counts
oh I would say yes then I'm sorry yes
not you don't have to die to get a
purple heart though so any of those get
a burial they have these like these like
um you know mailboxes you can get for
like some service
[Music]
um
yeah the funeral processions were pretty
cool oh you would actually see those
come in we'd see them yeah it was it was
pretty great I mean the military does it
right 21 gun salute and all that yeah it
would just be away and like
at that point we were like respectful
we're like we're not using our Gingy
[ __ ] complex Fired Up the Weed Wacker
yeah
so I remembering this too so one day
I mean it was cool I was I was a G1 so
they had this chart of like of like what
am I turning it I just go like this and
uh
um of where like you lay on the chart so
I was entry level 16 years old and just
started so I was in the top left corner
of the chart six dollars and 36 Cents an
hour damn and then if I worked again
next year I'd get like 670 and then
whatever it was fine it was plenty of
money back then
um
but meeting all these people so one day
we're all sitting talking I remember it
was like we're done like let's say we're
off at five I think we're up five was it
mostly guys only guys only okay only
guys so it was fun uh all Adrian any are
you the youngest old oh yeah I'm the
youngest there was another like 18 year
old hire I think but he was more of a
man I'm an orthodox Jew I came with my
yamaka and just like you know they asked
me a couple questions or is it for a Jew
on YouTube right now comedy special
um yeah and one day it was like I don't
know 4 40 and we were just back at the
at the at the clubhouse or whatever you
know where we eat our lunch and [ __ ] and
I was like I guess we're done you know
and I was like let me clock out and the
guy was like no [ __ ] you clock
out at five what the [ __ ] are you doing
I was like well we're done working he
goes no the job I was over at five it's
the [ __ ] manager whatever the foreman
and I was like but we're done he goes
That's not how it works
and it's like it's almost like I didn't
realize like I'm letting you guys off to
chill for 25 minutes don't [ __ ] it up by
clocking out early I didn't get any of
this the one oldest man he was great at
Spades and we play single Spades we
didn't play Team Spades it was like
every man for himself
he was talking one day and he goes he
has weird things happening where I'm
just like some fluids coming out of my
dick the head of my dick
and everyone was like what he goes yeah
I just got this like flu it's kind of
like and they're like what is it seeming
he goes yeah I think so and she's kind
of like leaking out and they're like
during sex and he was like no it's just
I'm older it just starts leaking out
there was like a respectful silence for
about 20 seconds and then they just
started killed oh yeah like first of all
like that's not normal that's not just
old yeah you're gonna die you have
untreated chlamydia for years
[Laughter]
oh my god
oh it was so great I forgot about that
guy too dude I haven't thought about
this place in so long dude I worked
you're making me think about this now I
worked it was the best I worked at UPS
with older black guys I worked at this
one place though it was called the
Baltimore Washington Auto Exchange okay
and it was an auto auction
and Monday to uh Friday it was uh I so
all right it was me and two of my
friends from high school that worked
there when we were in college and
everyone else was an older black dude
that was either laid off or you know
fired or just not work or whatever and
if you could get there by 9 A.M the
first I think it was like dozen people
could get um a dealer tag and your job
all day was to drive these nice Lincolns
Cadillacs whatever from lot a to Lot B
that's it they're like you're gonna take
you in this conoline van and we're gonna
take it a lot a and you're gonna drive
from the kovi lot to luskins that's that
was what he'd always say right okay and
you had to be there by nine if not then
you did the auction and the auction was
just driving these cars on the lot
through the thing or whatever no no no
no no no but on Thursdays if you drove
the uh the cars they made you do the
auction okay you had to do it at least
one day a week okay so we would get
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Friday that was
fun but because we were always driving
the nice cars we would get the [ __ ]
shitty cars at the auction and be like
you go get that 1976 Nissan 280Z with no
air conditioner or anything but ah and
You Pull It in people bid on it or
whatever but these older black dudes
were the funniest [ __ ] and they
didn't give a [ __ ] about anything
it was the dozens all the time it was
[ __ ] on everyone all the time and
people they're like you're people still
you're a ball bust I'm like that's just
I grew up around that everywhere and it
was just your friends yeah so this we
had strangers we had two guys that would
drive the van for us to go from lot kovi
lots of luskin's lot one guy was named
Wild Bill it was little dudes probably
like five five or a cowboy hat with
feathers on it like that old dude you
know what I mean with a vest and jeans
and cowboy boots and thought he ran [ __ ]
the other guy was this young dude that
was built very weird he had hips like he
had hips
and
I still can't believe it they would
[ __ ] yell to this kid while they were
he was driving he'd be driving hey [ __ ]
hips
and we would be in the [ __ ] back he's
like [ __ ] you he's like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
and the old man is like 10 of them or
nine of them are [ __ ] calling him but
they somewhere in his head he thinks the
[ __ ] you is going to get them to stop
and not way worse here we go yeah oh he
doesn't like [ __ ] yeah oh great guess
what and then they would start calling
him hog dick and that I don't even know
why we never found out like hey hog big
you missed that left man and they all be
like
and we would be in the back we never did
that like but we would be like [ __ ] yeah
oh man those older black dudes are funny
as [ __ ] I used to pick a guy up that
worked at UPS with me before I was uh
before I was a supervisor I unloaded
with him and his name was Daryl right to
think of Matthew passed them
no they get mad it's not that I passed
them I hustled to get that job they get
mad that who the [ __ ] do you think you
are you worked with me on Friday and on
Monday you're telling me what to do
right that's what they don't like UPS
should should promote you and move you
to it I was literally supervising the
guys I worked on not cool at all
man we got to pick it up everybody go
[ __ ] yourself damn you got me on were
you picking it up I'm going to the
bathroom going ahead they would do that
and take a break I'm like you
[ __ ] they would do everything I
know yeah but um this dude was a drinker
and he was about to get fired and I
liked them so much as an older dude and
I was like sometimes yeah always yeah
I'm like we can kick back and I go you
need to chew gum he's like you're good
to me Ryan I was a I become a supervisor
gum don't get me in trouble at least
like we're working together cover your
[ __ ] up so I'm a supervisor and I go to
this [ __ ] uh bar like a neighborhood
bar in Baltimore city right by um
oh what was the [ __ ] school there it
was Cardinal Gibbons and what was the
other big one there uh it'll come to me
later but um
I go pick them up and it's a local
Baltimore bar it's only black people in
there and I walk in and it's like that
record scratch moment and they're like
I'm like I'm here to get Daryl and they
just stare at you
and then some everybody stared at you
but one guy in like the middle of the
crowd's like Daryl you know what I mean
but still staring like yeah and then
Daryl comes out and he's like what's up
man I'm like oh thank
and I'm like chew gum and I take them to
work and I make sure he's all right he's
always giving me the thumbs up and then
the [ __ ] ends up stealing and
then they I can't help you know I
protect you all I could yeah did
everything I could for you bro I loved
working with those guys they were so
funny so much ball busting and making
you laugh about [ __ ] I still remember
that it sounds like it's like tips
it's like what a good way like yeah we
got to be at work but let's not be
mentally working yeah let's have fun
with this boy yeah yeah
we had one day
they grew a watermelon in the in the
yard yeah they were like planted one and
it was time to pick it now listen
I should say this is a disclaimer you
should say you should everybody likes
watermelon I love water it's a superfood
for me it's a super food it is a super
food
really yeah it's a superfood dogs love
watermelon that's the best chickens love
watermelon yeah everybody loves
watermelon
and they picked it I was like oh sweet
picnic food watermelon and man they
devoured that things I couldn't even
reach in there it was like Tasmanian
devil was like I was like whoa whoa what
is happening
oh my gosh and I didn't even know the
stereotype back then so I was just like
Jesus Christ years later I heard the
stereotype and I was like I think that
might be true
they do have a higher love of that of
that fruit than I do
[Laughter]
let's talk about the one thing that
might be missing from your daily routine
hydration liquid IV fuels your everyday
well-being by helping you stay hydrated
in just one stick you get five essential
vitamins and you're hydrating two times
faster than water alone it comes with
three times the electrolytes of
traditional sports drinks and it always
is made with premium ingredients we keep
liquid IV here at the studio we give it
to the guests we take it every morning
uh when I go to the gym I just throw it
in my water bottle Shake It Up and boom
I'm hydrating while I'm at the gym I
love the stuff last night at the show uh
The Comedy Store I gave a whole bag out
of it and they went nuts for it it was
like the Beatles showed up cooler
weather makes it easier to miss signs of
dehydration like overheating or
perspiration so it's even more important
to stay hydrated grab your liquid IV and
bulk nationwide at Costco or get 20 off
when you shop better hydration at liquid
iv.com and use code honey do a checkout
that's 20 off of anything with code
honeydew at liquid iv.com open
enrollment is here and that means now is
the time to take charge of your health
care decisions we all know the system
isn't working but thanks to crowd Health
we can do something about IT Crowd
Health puts the community back in
Community Health Care you pay one low
monthly total to fund your account your
monthly subscription helps fund
Healthcare cost of the entire crowd
Health Community there are no doctor
networks so you can see any doctor you
want and unlike insurance companies
crowd Health helps you find great care
at a fair price always pay doctors as
quickly as possible and actively
negotiates to keep cost down for
everyone take charge of your health care
today with crowd Health open enrollment
is the only time you can hit eject on
the broken system without penalty so
don't wait and for a limited time join
for just ninety nine dollars per month
for your first six months when you use
promo code honeydew at join
crowdhealth.com that's join
crowdhealth.com promo code honeydew
crowd health is not health insurance
it's a totally different way of paying
for health care term and conditions May
apply we are coming up on the holidays
and the last thing you want to worry
about is finding a great gift for
everyone on your list so in the spirit
of giving I'm sharing my go-to gift idea
premium audio products from raycon
raycon's wireless earbuds headphones and
speakers offer premium sound useful
features and almost custom comfortable
fit and up to 54 hours of battery life
anyone you give them to will find use
for them right away whether they use
speakers to start a party in the living
room or escape the party completely and
use the earbuds for some much needed Zen
meditation and as the person gifting
them you gotta love that they start at
half the price of other premium audio
Brands I love my raycons because they
block out all that extra background
noise and I never have to worry about
them falling out of my ear no matter
what I'm doing raycon makes this
stressful holiday period easy with
holiday gift guides for everyone in your
life for the next month Raycom will have
a countdown to Christmas with a new
pop-up flash deal for you to take
advantage of every single day you can
find your raycon in stores now like
Kohl's or Walmart but let me tell you
right now you're always going to get the
best deal at buyraacon.com Honeydew the
raycon website offers free shipping free
returns and buy now pay later options
plus a 30-day happiness guarantee right
now go to buy raycon.com honeydew to get
15 off site-wide with code holiday plus
free shipping that's code holiday at
byraycon.com Honeydew for 15 off your
raycon purchase buy raycon.com honeydew
now let's get back to the dude here is
the best day at Arlington National
Cemetery I cannot believe Ari shaffir
Jew yeah Patriot worked at the Arlington
National Cemetery I was gonna go back
next year I didn't go back the next year
I don't know why I think I started
delivering Domino's or something or two
years later this was the best day at
Arlington
we're on our lunch break we all got back
there we're eating our bag lunch so we
had the trucks you know you could get
they'd come up and whatever
and uh we're about ready to go out we
had this little TV in in one of the side
rooms to play it was like the the
Foreman's office then the side room
where we have a couple tables and like
there's other place Spades and this
other room a couple couches a little TV
they smoked
um you can smoke inside back then smoke
on planes but you could smoke yeah and
then eventually like half and half yeah
curtain I barely remember that but you
remember it too right ashtray they had
those ashtrays like yeah
um yeah I remember at some point you
were like man how old is this they still
got the hash I know they soldered it
shut up but this is an old plane yeah
um anyway we're about to leave
and I was watching TV the news was on or
something it was soap operas and then
the new and and then they broke in and
it was like come on let's go we're going
back out there
and I saw Marion Barry on the on the TV
and I was like and I was a hero I go
hold up hold up you guys hold on and
they're like what I'm like hold on one
second and all I just saw was the mayor
of Washington DC
saying the words [ __ ] set me up
yeah let's just cracked yeah it set me
up and I was like what they're like what
is it I'm like just I don't know come
look at this
and man we got the rest of the day off
we all just looked at the nudes for the
rest of the day Mary and Barry got
caught the mayor mayor of them the most
capital of the United States of America
got caught being set up by a hooker what
was her name I don't remember her name
she was famous for a little while for
this
and and some crack for crack selling him
crack he was in a hotel room with you
know those fake hotel rooms with another
hotel room right next where they're just
like cameras are in there they busted in
and he was like [ __ ] set me up he was
just buying crack for his hooker
looking back no big deal you know why he
still ran the government he got
reelected he got realized re-elected he
he was running a city that just didn't
care about crack the way anyone else
might care about it they were like
that's actually not a bigger deal yeah
you got to go to jail but that's not
it's like in Berlin if you get caught
cheating on your wife they're like
it's like I'm trying to think what you
know what I mean was like your standards
are not my standards
but Toronto mayor did it too remember
that guy he was on crack too and they're
like yeah
I think he won too didn't he get
realized he might have yeah John Ford he
just died right not John Ford something
Ford I don't know but yeah he was like
[ __ ] shut me out he just kept saying
[ __ ] set me up yeah and we all sat
around I got a bunch of Atta boys for
[ __ ] spots yeah
yeah we watched Marion Baron everyone's
like can you believe this news is like
this is what a day for us yeah what a
thing you know how we're gonna cover
local volleyball scores
you know it's dead the [ __ ] mayor
with the hooker by crack yeah I later
metaphors with Rogan and we were there
and he walked by and then [ __ ] Norton
sprung into action he walked by doing
somebody else and he goes Mr Barry uh I
think he was in between uh mayor and not
mayor and the mayor again because we'd
love to interview him because sure he
just thought radio station he didn't
think morning Zoo
and and he was like Norton was like
trying to give it up for him he's like
you know we are a testimony to like a
testament to the uh the American dream
you can like sink to the depths and
overcome you know this terrible thing
and still become oh you had America and
become mayor again yeah and not mayor of
a city or in Tucson South Dakota yep
it's not Bismarck it's not something
deep Washington DC yeah
the capital Black America to be honest
it's an important [ __ ] town and he
goes uh what do you mean sing to the
depths he goes well you know the
the the the arrest you know for for
crack because I never it wasn't an
arrest for crack and we're like what he
goes I never did crack
and then we're all kind of Silent for a
minute and we're like what do you what
do you mean he goes nope they didn't
catch me with crack that wasn't real
crack
because I guess it was one of those
things we need to buy but you couldn't
like sell it sell fake tickets for you
know you can't sell them you can't sell
them so yeah I better pin them for crack
because what they're selling them but
you can get them for the purchase and
Rogan's like but what did you think you
were buying and he goes and he just
leaves he was like I'm done with this
yeah he takes off oh man Marion Barry
was great great speaker
ran the government well
people loved him
they love them so much they re-elected
them they got caught on camera I wasn't
even like ah the images burned in our
minds he kind of felt bad for him he's
like he [ __ ] set him up [ __ ] shut me
upset him shut me up like as soon as
they busted he realized oh I'm here with
this [ __ ] hooker God what was her
name God remember her name when you see
her name you will remember it you grew
up in that region I think she was
internationally known there's a couple
hookers Stormy Daniels or whatever well
you're like you were divine Brown Divine
brown one of them was a Hugh Hef the
black girl that got uh Hugh Hefner got
busted with was big foreign no Divine
Brown was the line brown was the guy
from Four Weddings and a funeral that's
who I mean not Hugh Hefner Hugh Grant
Hugh Grant Divine Brown you can't lie
you're just a [ __ ] hooker and now
your International stuff the actor's
dick and everybody knows your name yeah
and you didn't even tell you just got
caught yeah that's right so you can even
have the moral High Ground that's right
like I'm not gonna say [ __ ] I cut my
dick my mouth was full
of the most beautiful [ __ ] you've ever
smelled beautiful British cotton oh my
God
yeah what a [ __ ] day
good job that was it was everybody
we should have said that to him that's
what you know your worst day was mama I
should have I should have been like I
I'm part of this story somehow I know
very minor later you won't appreciate it
Mr Barry
mayor Barry but man you really made my
day God damn
and so what'd you do after that then
I deliver pizzas for Domino's deliver
flowers I got fired from delivering
pizzas why would you do I'd steal a lot
how'd they catch you uh what are you
stealing food are you stealing the money
and the tips the money the tips so we
had a thing after 30 minutes
um they used to have after 30 minutes of
pizza is free until that car accident
killed somebody yeah you killed somebody
rushing to knock out free pizza out and
they're like hey you can't incentivize
people to speed like that yeah for real
you just give them a ten dollar Pizza
you [ __ ] five dollars off yeah is what
we changed too they even said during the
training you know it's [ __ ] about
Donald they make you buy the shorts and
the shirt they don't just give it to you
they make you buy it comes out of your
check yeah so the first like three weeks
you're only getting paid did they saw
that hat it is a cool hat now it's a
trucker Style with the touch in the back
yeah would you get the any aggressive
people like hey you're after 30 minutes
would you get that a lot absolutely yeah
and then you give them the three dollars
off five dollars off now here's the cool
thing
if you're getting the pizza out the door
at 25 right if it's like because
sometimes they're back they're
backlogged sometimes you're getting a 35
that's already five dollars off you know
you get it it's like sorry it's gonna
take an hour to get there you know in
busy season uh you know Super Bowl kind
of [ __ ]
um you get as fast as you can but
they're not getting there so give them
all five dollars off
um at 25 like assume you didn't make it
and then I picked up a pizza at 25 like
assume that's a five dollars off got
there in four minutes
and the guy was like okay he just made
it and he gave me full price and I'm
like well hold on
the store told me it's gonna be five
dollars off this guy doesn't expect it
because I got there under 30 minutes and
then the Jew bulb went off
and I'm like I'm an entrepreneur
so anytime I was close
I'm picking up the pizza after 25 or
getting there at like 32 33 minutes most
people didn't realize about the deal and
everything was cash then everything was
cash everything you didn't bring a
[ __ ] thing with swipe and pay and
tablets you couldn't even pay on the
phone cash
sometimes you'd be there nowhere to be
there but [ __ ] and they taught
me like if anybody gives you a 10 cent
tip just like keep the change on 990 go
no no no I'll get your change hold on
right here you go back to your car get a
dime like there you are sir just store
it in their [ __ ] face
um so I got the 32 33 minutes and I'm
like here's your pizza 20 let's say
twenty dollars now if they go well hold
on it's uh it's been 33 minutes you go
oh my God you're absolutely right 15 it
is no big deal if they didn't mention it
you tell the store five dollars off so
you're skimming five on every delivery
yeah okay eventually it becomes like hey
man you're not you're missing a lot of
the you're getting late a lot you're
giving these people five dollars off
you're not getting there in time
um you're not learning a route one time
I ran out of gas and I didn't I was just
like [ __ ] I just I was an idiot you know
so I was like I had to walk and [ __ ]
get a bucket and [ __ ] fill up my gas
and [ __ ] it whatever so he's like you're
not loading around we gotta let you go
he didn't fully accuse me of stealing
but that's what I was doing that's why I
was late every single delivery how much
you pulling a night
we average about two dollars and ten
cents a tip you know and then sometimes
we deliver to like um Georgetown prep or
something like that big order and get
along five plus the five so I'm I'm
average six seven a pizza yeah and how
many are you ripping
oh yeah oh yeah when I got when it was
like eventually it was like hey we gotta
let you go it's like worth it you know I
got fired a month early I I did four
months extra worth of work yeah oh worth
it
I was embarrassed though I was too
embarrassed to go pick up my last
paycheck to get fired as a Jew it's like
the conservative household you're just
like you don't get fired from jobs and I
remember the first time getting fired
too I felt ashamed and ashamed I did I
felt like whoa I must have this I must
be terrible at this or whatever and I'm
like that's just ain't for me yeah you
don't have any passion thing yeah
what's the craziest [ __ ] you saw
delivering pizza
um I mean you gotta see some weird [ __ ]
showing yeah we saw something on their
doors yeah we saw a full like [ __ ]
going on what do you mean like they're
trying to show off some people are
trying to be choked by Chuck palahnik
there's this like theory that some
people like being seen so you'll go open
the door in the in the in the airplane
and someone like hey I'm like oh [ __ ]
sorry and then it's like why didn't they
lock that door they want you to see them
you know they're these voyeurs that like
want are the opposite whatever that want
you to say they don't lock doors on
purpose so that you'll walk in on them
so they're open the door there's [ __ ]
going on there's a naked lady on a bed I
remember going like
what this guy in a [ __ ] short robe
you know yeah the porn rope it's like hi
I mean he's opening it wide
she was just on bed smoking naked they
were [ __ ] with me they were [ __ ]
with delivery boy and this little
[ __ ] you know yiddle diddle with his
yamaka I hadn't seen anything like this
before because they told me that might
happen that you someone asked for this
Special Sauce but looking back like
that's lying nobody no housewife ever
did that for you wouldn't talk about
semen Ryan I'm talking about scene but
coming over to [ __ ] yeah okay
okay yeah we never ate we never ate
anything we never took any toppings off
not me anyway spit on it none of that
good good we're just good for the pizza
there's no time you'd have to know it's
a shitty Tipper who keeps ordering
none of that
O'Neill and danish used to deliver to uh
Drew Carey all the time and he would tip
100 bucks every time damn yeah
they did yummy.com I'd fist fight to get
that [ __ ] Pizza well sometimes
whatever girl he was dating would open
the door and they'd be like oh and they
tip like five a normal amount you know
and they're like we really should
deliver this to Mr carius he homes like
he's in the back room he's like we'd
really like to put in his hand ourselves
dude there's nothing like a good Tipper
I got a job at a law firm and uh and it
was a 10 an hour job which was [ __ ]
great ended at 12 I mean I could and I
was like if I get this job I'm gonna do
the next pizza delivery guy and give him
a 20 tip
as like a [ __ ] thank you to my roots
you know I got the job
I was over my friend Aaron Levine's
place at University of Maryland in his
dorm not his dorm his off-campus housing
and this guy gave him a 20. he goes they
didn't even [ __ ] react I was so
[ __ ] pissed two minutes later knocked
on the door he goes hey I think you
tipped me wrong I didn't even see it and
I was like hell yeah no man that's for
you I was like [ __ ] yeah thank you
that's what you want dude I [ __ ] uh
found okay I'm walking at the park one
day yeah okay I find a check on the
ground personal check and it's for like
eight thousand dollars oh right and I
look at it and it's got the person's
full name and address on it I'm like oh
[ __ ] that's right over here half a block
away so I'm like I'm gonna be a a good
person and go return this check cool I
go return the check dude's like what's
up like I'm walking at the park over
here and I found this check are you so
whatever Sean he's like yeah I guess
eight thousand dollar check just laying
on the ground he's like thanks shut the
door in my face
what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] was it bro that was it it
was a lot and I wanted to be like P.S
what the [ __ ] do you do for a living
yeah what do you do for a living yeah
yeah but it could have been in the yard
who gives a [ __ ] you know like uh damn I
lost my skank Fest check I left it in
the bin at TSA I had no idea and I got a
[ __ ] DM on on Instagram or something
from who this guy who found my check no
way what TSA just holding it or anything
those [ __ ] you'll see something
like hey there's like a really nice
lighter or something like a pen or like
a Ralph's Club Card keys and he's like
hey I might drop keys I'm like what are
you doing I'm like I'm doing what you
should be doing yeah seriously
somebody's life is gonna be [ __ ]
really put out because you're [ __ ]
searching us for no [ __ ] reason
caught a single goddamn terrorist oh for
two
um over two yeah two people try they
both got on since 9 11. is that right
they got all the shoe guy in the
underwear they both got right off you've
done absolutely [ __ ] off and everyone's
losing their keys the shoe guy losing
their key yeah one time this Asian guy
was like Pat me down and I Pat him down
my shoes I was like you can't search me
and I was like whatever and he's like I
was like why do you do the shoe things
it's because the shoe bomber and I was
like yeah you guys really [ __ ] up on
that one didn't you he got right on what
happened there big loss huh and he goes
yeah I'm like this is demeaning your
culture right touching a man's shoes and
he was like come on Sir go on Sir
um wait that reminded me of something
delivering
delivering pizzas making tips
he had voyers you said yeah but did
somebody finding something for you oh
you were talking about uh yeah tipping
that guy 20 bucks and he was stoked and
I was like I found this check and the
guy didn't give a [ __ ] yeah they should
give a [ __ ] I mean I find a [ __ ]
eight thousand dollar check what was he
gonna do you know I remember go
I was uh I got back from Southeast Asia
and I hadn't seen anybody went right to
the Nashville Comedy Festival I told
Abrams and I was like uh I was like I
sent him a letter I was like I know you
guys want to do the Wild West Comedy
Fest we had a show with Third Man
Records which would have been very cool
you know uh Jack White's record company
and I was like I know you guys are
talking about that I'm staying longer
Off the Grid than I than I planned and I
wrote him a lot I was like if you guys
still want to do that add me to the
website I don't have my I don't have
access to email my email's locked out on
purpose my Instagram my Facebook all of
us locked out my phone's in my drawer at
home uh in in uh in New York and I was
like if I see that shows on the website
I will be there I'll find well I think
at that time I was in Indonesia when I
sent the letter
they added to the site I showed up
hadn't seen anybody Bert kreischer's
there knocks on my door he's like I
think Ari's here knocks in my door
[ __ ] quickly took off all my clothes
open the doors come on dude I'm like
welcome back to me
um
he's all excited I think Abrams is in
the room for this actually
and he goes dude I just made the most
money I've ever made in my life at a
club I think he did the San Jose Improv
I'll be there in March uh it's a big
venue and he filled it up for the first
time and he goes it's it was seventy
thousand dollars it was so [ __ ] much
he makes that much [ __ ] breathing now
yeah but like uh he was like look at
this [ __ ] check not rubbing at my
face but showing off sometimes we see
rich people bragging it's not that
they're [ __ ] callous it's that they
still view themselves as this [ __ ]
nobody you know they've just started
making fun of this right can you believe
it and you realize who you're talking to
like oh [ __ ] but it's also like you're
excited about it and he's like look at
this I was like God damn Bert that's
[ __ ] awesome
and they realized it's like they'll
re-cut the check but I'm like it was so
[ __ ] worried he's like I'll be the
sound
[Music]
oh [ __ ] I had a lady hit me up this is
like
this is I want to say money during the
pandemic when I really needed that
[ __ ] money too but uh this lady hits
me up and she's like hey I live in your
old apartment and I said I haven't lived
in that apartment for like 10 years and
she goes well I got this mail that I
just assumed was for me and I opened it
turns out it's for you and it's a check
from Blue Shield for like I don't know
like three thousand dollars and it says
well the check's not there it says that
they owe me this and I have X amount of
days to claim it and I go well how many
days they said 30 and I go well it's
there's only like three days left she
goes yep and they just mailed it I just
got this I say you know what's [ __ ] up
I haven't lived there for 10 years and
I've had Blue Shield they managed to
send me my bill every [ __ ] this
is that interesting
every [ __ ] month comes right to
my mailbox but this one and it says on
there if it's not claimed it'll go to
whatever some thing and so she I said
look this is mine
I said I'd love to give you a cut of
this I'll give you 20 and she's like I
don't want anything I'm like come on
she's like I want to go [ __ ] them I'll
help she said helping you is all I want
I said I'll gladly make a donation into
whatever you want any charity you want
whatever nope refuse to take it and
because of that I got like three
thousand pounds nice and I just started
wondering like how many [ __ ] times
are they doing that [ __ ] to people
because they did I knew they had
overcharged I had one year I'd hit my
ten thousand dollar but they kept
charging me I'm like yeah they always
just like you owe us money I haven't
been back to the hospital I paid you I
know I paid you off complete and now
suddenly I owe you and then I'm sure if
I looked into it enough they'd be like
oh yeah it turns out you're fine like
but I'm in collections now and I'm like
how did you find me she's like it was
pretty easy to find it's Google Now I
was like oh yeah yeah dude on the way
home from the store once I found a
license and I was like let me look her
up and I was like Hey same thing it's
your license it's it's very annoying
can't you just drop that in the mailbox
won't they mail that to you since it has
your address on on it yeah I could have
but I was like hey you lost your license
yeah
you know yeah sure
um looked her up she was googleable or
or whatever she had an Instagram
um she's like she's sweet she makes
candles is when I was living in LA
so I'll come get it
um okay gave it to her I went into Dr
Drew and she's [ __ ] one of his
assistants or something no way yeah she
goes you saved my [ __ ] yeah how about
that yeah
yeah it's nice when you help somebody
out when you just make the decision to
be like I'm gonna do a little bit of
work here and then it comes back like
that that's crazy
that's crazy they were sending to the
wrong [ __ ] remember when Obama came
into office and he goes I am going to
invite CNN into the votes on reforming
health care I want it on televise what
we're doing I'm that's what he's running
on and then he got into office and every
[ __ ] Senator and Congressman where
he's like let's get CNN they were like
nah dude because we're on the tank and
we can't be seeing what our votes is
we'll say we're here for the little man
but Obama was like what do you mean I
can't [ __ ] show you about him like no
because we got to have our takes
and they never fully reformed it no they
just did little pieces here or there
they're still so [ __ ] crooked every
time something hurt you're like oh well
maybe we should that's what all like
this whole legalization of marijuana
yeah the states that are slow on it once
they see the money that comes in they're
they're not going to put it toward
teachers firemen police infrastructure
they're gonna line their [ __ ]
all this money yeah a no-show job that's
my mom told me like how'd the elections
go did you see the I'm like I don't even
look no it's like you don't know how I
went like I don't know who won who was
like what do I care they're all [ __ ]
they're still counting oh really how you
still I don't know if it's not you still
counting too
like there's an election every four
months so stupid what else give me one
more give me another one what else I do
hoods of flowers for a while that was
the worst tipping job because you didn't
have to pay it was already paid for so
you show up to someone's house and you
make their [ __ ] month
flat like what oh my God thank you
I'm like come on I think I made two
dollars ever ever and it was so much
better than a piece Where Are you
delivering like people's work and homes
people's homes I just had a memory
that's gonna get me in a lot of trouble
uh delivering flowers deliver flowers to
a church so we did a lot of funerals and
now at the time I'm trying to masturbate
in as many weird places as I can I see
why does it go I don't know man how old
are you
18 publicly or private privately but on
planes are like you're not flying over
Arkansas I'm like Arkansas and I run to
the bathroom and jerk off oh you're
doing in the bathroom yeah and just
throw a blanket over here yeah one time
on the way to Australia I jerked off in
my seat one of those lie down beds and I
was like I think I could do it here I
lined up like who can see me there who
can see me there and at first I was
turned away but I'm like now I can't see
if a stewardess comes by so I turn they
give me these socks so first class Rogan
ticket UFC ticket just [ __ ] jerked
off into one of these [ __ ] nice socks
I give you ah nice Qantas they really
give yourself Quanto semen yeah they
give you these little these little
footies to walk around oh it's great you
you line up full bed you know you're
like oh screen screen me and Rogan did a
podcast uh on it yeah oh hell yeah way
back
um not video just audio Yeah Larson and
I then went on a train back in the day
on the crap off the West Coast from uh
Phoenix or Phoenix Portland uh Seattle
on the train
you show up too because it's 13 hours
from LA
and you're like oh I was so [ __ ] nut
everyone I was like
because he gets regular seats oh but
like um
what were we talking about delivering
flowers is the worst tipping job so I
went to the delivered some funeral stuff
to uh to a church that was that happened
five percent of the time it happened
plenty of times
um can I use the bathroom sure and now
I'm in a church in a secluded you know
it's daytime and I'm like oh hell yeah I
was right at the urinal I just [ __ ]
not even in a stall no
yeah looking back that's a that's a fair
fair
I didn't even consider it I didn't even
think of it
and I just [ __ ] shot alone right now
you know where that fly is on the thing
yeah yeah and I just [ __ ] blasted my
young calm too yeah and it you know [ __ ]
you could hit something you can blind
somebody with that [ __ ] yeah
also when you could come quick today it
would take me a lot longer to do that
yeah exactly I was just like I was just
like touching it my dick we're ready oh
my God oh my God
jerked off in a church what a flower
delivery I think I'm at church on
Georgia Avenue
sorry Monsignor
oh [ __ ] dude that's so funny when you
say that when you're like why not a
stall I'm like yep didn't even consider
that you ever get like now that you're
an adult I had this is a product cut out
of my special that now that I'm an adult
I'll like go back to my childhood with
an adult mind and realize all the stuff
that I didn't realize back then yeah I
ended up having to cut it out but how
like your parents always knew when you
were lying I had no idea I thought I had
them fooled right the chicks you could
have hooked up with
man I tell you I've had women come to me
you know in the past just a few years
and be like how come you never asked me
out I'm like you were interested like
yeah
I was telling you this Tanya we should
do that I'm like oh my God yeah
[ __ ] I'm an idiot I'm an idiot I didn't
think anybody want but also the women in
my life the good women in my life if
like I'll say something they're like you
did that or you what and I'm like oh my
God yeah like they pointed out silly
yeah yeah we used to do that
tab well dude I know you got to get out
of here you got to go get on your run
here for your special so promote it one
more time please always your fear Jew
it's on YouTube right now it's the best
special I've ever done it's the best one
I'm gonna and it's a concept special too
content special but mostly I don't want
anybody thinking it's Jessica it's just
stand up every one of these bits follows
Bobby Lee at the store follows Mark
Norman at the [ __ ] stand just like
they're just [ __ ] funny funny bits
you will walk away with it on some other
level thing uh but they're just
hilarious stand-up comedy bits and um
I I was like I spent a lot of money on
it I'm giving away for free there's a
donate button on there if you want to
help me pay for some of this I'm out a
shitload of money that's up to you it's
a gift to all of you and if you liked it
go ahead and throw some cash back into
the [ __ ] Kitty but either way I'm
just giving it to you guys to enjoy
um
thanks you're gonna hit your you're
gonna exceed your goal uh maybe you
already have you already exceeded your
million in a month oh yeah my goal there
yeah oh yeah the money I'm about 45 paid
so we'll see I'm still like I can't
afford it might be for real yeah and uh
I'll come I want to come promote mine oh
for sure so yeah if you're out there
especially coming to New York if yeah if
you're here in La December 14th
Wednesday at the Dynasty come see me
shoot the special second Show tickets
available there are only a few left and
I think it was one of the realest comics
in the world you guys there's no way
you're not gonna have a good time this
is how my friends when they used to ask
me like when I started comedy they go
like hey I see the DC Improv like
website uh who should I go and you're
like oh you'll have a great time with
that one you'll have a great time with
that I just know Sickler's the real deal
I can guarantee you without having seen
you on stage for the last two years your
new stuff is hilarious you don't [ __ ]
falter no so go see his [ __ ] joke be
there live yeah be there Live use code
sickler you'll get half off your tickets
follow me on all social media we'll talk
to y'all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]